are you ready to learn a bunch of
amazing facts about jujutsu kaisen that
you probably didn't know of course you
are let's get started the creator of
jujutsu kaisen goes by the name gege
agutami but that's probably not his real
name his gender is also unknown but it's
believed that he is male according to
the author of jujutsu kaisen the king of
all curses ryoman sukuna never had a
wife or children gojo can cast domain
expansion multiple times a day while
others are limited to only once a day so
far there are only four jujutsu users
who are on a special level they are goju
satoru sugurugeto yuta okotsu and
tsukumo yuki yuji was superhuman even
before obtaining cursed energy he was
nicknamed the tiger of west junior high
for his strength and stamina his
superhuman strength has been known to
let him destroy walls bend goal posts
and at some point even throw a car as
far as speed is concerned he was able to
run a 50 meter race in three seconds
absolutely destroying the competition
the zenin clan family home is derived
from an architectural museum in tokyo
called korakarayu gojo is a huge fan of
gundam he has a collection of these
models too at a young age toji would get
thrown into a group of cursed spirits
the scar on his lip is a result of that
akutami deliberately changed the
hairstyle of yuta okotsu and inumaki
toge so they wouldn't look alike with
megumi and yuji the eye within goju's
domain expansion is that of a black hole
or at least resembles a black hole like
in most anime the characters in jujutsu
kaizen are primarily japanese however
there are a few characters who are both
japanese and something else kento
nanami's grandfather is danish making
him one quarter danish and three
quarters japanese momo nishimiya's
mother is japanese while her father is
american making her half japanese and
half american suguru ghetto's character
is inspired by shinobu sensui from yuyu
hakusho both of them were on the good
side once and then became evil ever
since goju was born cursed spirits and
cursed users hid in the shadows due to
goju possessing both the six eyes and
the limitless curse technique making him
literally impossible to defeat gojo's
six eyes also known as rikugon reduce
gojo's curse energy consumption allowing
him to never run out of cursed energy
majito likes perry the platypus from the
animated series phineas and ferb that's
why he made june pay like that a lot of
people compare goju to kakashi from
naruto but there's one area in which
they're complete opposites while kakashi
can't stand sweet food gojo loves it at
first he started consuming more sugar to
boost his brain power but he ended up
getting obsessed with all sweet things
there are two light novels released
before the anime version soaring summer
and returning autumn and the path of
roses at dawn kento nanami is one of the
most responsible and kind-hearted
characters in the series but he might
not have been that way if akutami had
stuck to his original idea nanami was
originally planned to be a villain what
his role would have been is not really
clear but he certainly would have been
different from the anonymity we know
today megumi's birthday is on december
22nd yuji's is on march 20th and nobaras
is on august 7th akutami once tried
drawing noritoshi to look like a
japanese comedian gorgeous but most
people who saw the drawing thought that
he looked like a member of kiss instead
this was revealed in noritoshi's profile
in the manga unfortunately the drawing
itself was not included because his
heavenly restriction keeps him from
going outside mutta uses mekamaru as a
proxy while the name mekamaru seems like
a fairly straightforward choice it has a
specific origin it's from the anime that
muta enjoys one of the more unsettling
elements of jujutsu kaisen is the fact
that itadori literally swallows sukuna's
fingers while itadori makes it pretty
clear that he finds the fingers
disgusting he doesn't describe what they
taste like but in a fanbook q a akutami
said that they tasted like soap still
gross but not quite what we were
expecting masamichi yaga was goju's
teacher when goji was young akutami had
planned to kill yuji after sukuna ripped
out his heart in the cursed woo mark in
the manga later he decided to change his
mind since the manga was doing very well
in shonen jump the show doesn't spend a
lot of time focusing on megumi's
relationship with his shikigami but it
turns out that he does care a lot about
them whenever they're destroyed he gets
super upset about it in fact losing his
shikigami impacts him more deeply than
losing a person would when he was in
high school goju was a big fan of
digimon he still seems to be into it now
since he occasionally references it in
the manga incidentally both goju sub and
dub voice actors yuichi nakamura and
kaiji tang have played digimon
characters before when goju was a
teenager he could never perform the
cursed technique reversal red not until
he learned to generate true positive
energy my hero academia's author kohei
horikoshi is a known fan of jujutsu
kaizen and a personal friend of akutami
the two creators have done a lot
together and have even created crossover
art apparently horikoshi's favorite jjk
character is majito a villainous cursed
spirit nobara loves shopping but ever
since she came to the city she didn't
have any free time to do so did you ever
wonder what would happen if yuji ate a
death painting you probably didn't but
we're still going to answer it if he ate
one instead of eating sucuna's finger
yuji would be able to override the
consciousness of the cursed womb and
would be able to use its cursed energy
megumi keeps track of local news but he
rarely if ever believes what it says
junpei's story was one of the saddest
things about jiu jitsu kaizen especially
in the anime which included a few
original scenes that helped round out
his character nobody's reddish brown
hair looks great on her but it isn't her
natural color without hair dye she'd
have dark brown hair yuji's name comes
from one of akutami's former classmates
it's not clear whether this has any
meaning or if akutami simply liked the
name his surname itadori is a type of
medicinal plant that's also known as
japanese knotweed it can be used as a
pain reliever or as a vitamin-rich food
in this scene you probably noticed that
hanami's voice doesn't exactly sound
normal this effect was achieved by
having hanami's voice actor speak the
lines in japanese the lines were then
played in reverse todo might not seem
like the type of guy who cares that much
about personal hygiene but he makes sure
to shower use deodorant and otherwise
keep his grooming on point yuji has a
strong resistance to poison we are first
introduced to this when he fights jun
pay and resisting moon drake's poison
it's possible that he developed this as
a result of eating sukuna's fingers
since tsukuna was known as the king of
poisons as he had absolute mastery over
them jujutsukai's an anime was a huge
success however when the manga was first
released in 2018 it didn't attract much
of an audience 600 000 copies at the
peak isn't bad but it was definitely
less than it deserved as soon as people
started realizing the potential of the
manga things went crazy hence in just a
year the sales went up more than 400
yuta was originally supposed to be a
main character on the show but akutami
decided that it would be itadori instead
jujutsu kaizen won the best shonen anime
award in 2021 megumi is thought to be a
student with the highest potential even
higher than itadoris the literal
translation of jujutsu kaizen is sorcery
fight akutami already has the series
ending all planned out even though the
manga has still a long way to go kento
nami is the most professional jujutsu
sorcerer in the series the reason behind
this is that he was originally an office
worker before he quit his job after
quitting he still adores the same
discipline in his life and as you all
know he hates working overtime when goju
first explains the ancient threat of
ryomen sukuna he makes it clear that
sukuna once ruled over the world of
jujutsu with four fists despite the fact
that tsukuna's 20 fingers are pivotal to
the plot of jujutsu kaizen it's still
unclear how or why the ancient sorcerer
had four arms in the first place
jiu-jitsu kaizen manga sold more than 55
million copies worldwide and is expected
to end in approximately two years most
of the locations shown in the first
opening are real-life locations in japan
in order to avoid unwanted effects from
his cursed speech toge has to speak in
rice ball toppings instead of actual
words but he's not just speaking
randomly his words have meaning he uses
shaki which translates to salmon as an
affirmation negation is okaka which
translates to fish flakes konbu or kelp
is a greeting those are the only three
with meanings the rest are complete
nonsense click on this video to see all
the things you missed in demon slayer